[Musique]
je
j'aimerais bien revenez dans votre
magazine mode d'emploi cette semaine
nous allons aborder la question de la
formation professionnelle des adultes
pour nous en parler j'aurai le plaisir
de recevoir une spécialiste de la
question
mais tout de suite votre sommaire
aujourd'hui je vous emmène à l'afpa
d'elancourt cette agence propose de
nombreuses formations qualifiantes
certifiantes et préparatoires dans le
tertiaire
nous partirons ensuite à la découverte
d'une entreprise qui a choisi
d'améliorer ses performances en
proposant à ses collaborateurs des
formations au sein de la société pour
acquérir des compétences et trouver un
métier pour évoluer au sein de votre
entreprise ou tout simplement pour
élaborer un projet professionnel
vous avez décidé de passer une formation
jusque là tout va bien
mais laquelle choisir une formation
préparatoire certifiante qualifiante
comment faut-il procéder serait vous
rémunérez qui peut vous financer
combien de temps va t elle durer
conformation rime avec questions les
réponses c'est tout de suite
chacun suit au cours de sa jeunesse une
formation initiale statut scolaire pour
les élèves statut universitaire pour les
étudiants ou encore statut d'apprenti en
contrat d'apprentissage
ensuite ceux qui s'engagent dans la vie
active bénéficie de la formation
professionnelle continue
en face de la demande il ya les offres
ce sont deux prestataires de formation
ils sont plus de 8500 france dont
l'activité principale est la formation
et 241 dans les yvelines à 97 % relèvent
du secteur privé les autres étant des
organismes publics comme par exemple
marche pas pendant sa formation le
candidat éliminé
et le financement est assurée soit par
l'état et les régions soit par les
entreprises ou soit par les particuliers
eux mêmes enfin il ya les opca
organismes paritaires collecteurs agréés
qui collecte de financement et leur
distribuer la formation continue
comporte des modalités d'accès
différents selon les profils des
candidats
on distingue le cif congé individuel de
formation
la vf ou validation des acquis par
l'expérience le cpf ou congés personnels
de formation le plan de formation
le pee ou préparation opérationnelle à
l'emploi la période de
professionnalisation et le contrat
d'alternance pour nous en parler
aujourd'hui du reçoit sine die hard au
bonjour lisa bonjour vous êtes
conseiller en formation chez opcalia
donc anelka alors tout d'abord première
question qu'est ce cas d'autres cas
alors les opca sont des organismes
collecteurs agréés par l'état qui
collecte auprès des entreprises et une
cotisation au titre de la formation
professionnelle continue
ces fonds sont mutualisés et ensuite ils
sont distribués via des dispositifs pour
financer des formations des salariés
alors une entreprise comment va-t-elle
définir si je puis dire sont notre cas
alors soit par saint-gaudens hossa
convention collective en imaginant je
suis directeur d'un petit salon
d'esthétique appris que je souhaite soit
formé mais salariés pour améliorer
éventuellement leurs compétences oui je
souhaite avoir un apprenti et je
souhaite qu'ils soient financés dans ça
c'est bien de cas de figure comment ça
se passe concrètement que je prends
contact avec mon conseiller formation
auprès de nos cas en question rouge et
cotisé et on en lui demandant les
mondanités
de prise en charge donc c'est très
simple l'entreprise a le droit de
choisir son prestataire donc l'organisme
de formation choisir la formation en
question qui l'intéressent et faire part
de son devis a sans aucun pour lui
demander un financement abondant
quelques instants libre de votre
question très bien tout de suite nous
avons joué avec l'afpa association pour
la formation professionnelle des adultes
devenu pour 2017
l' agence nationale pour la formation
professionnelle des adultes c'est un
centre de formation bien sûr mais que
vous êtes également dans toutes vos
démarches et partie premier organisme en
france de formation professionnelle pour
adultes
l'afpa propose 235 formation qualifiante
dans 135 métiers différents
une chance quand on sait que 61 % des
stagiaires sont en poste seulement six
mois après leur formation à elancourt de
formation qualifiante sont proposés dans
le tertiaire et 500 stagiaires sont
formés chaque année les formations
accessibles à tous jamais seniors
demandeurs d'emploi ou salariés avaient
des modalités de financement propre à
chacun si tous les tests sont positifs
et entretiens positifs
il est inscrit où elle est inscrite à la
formation
ça c'est un premier parcours ensuite
pour le salarié est bien le salarié il a
plusieurs possibilités soit il fait un
congé individuel de formation ou soit
c'est directement l'entreprise qui
financent la formation
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 90 %
demanderont pro ce sont des formations
qui sont financés principalement par le
conseil régional
les domaines de compétence de lagence
touche le secrétariat le service à la
personne
le secteur médico-social et l'entretien
au logement la comptabilité gestionnaire
de paie et contrôleurs de gestion ainsi
qu'aux utilisateurs de logiciel
comptabilité et gestion des secteurs où
l' agence privilégie l'apprentissage par
le geste professionnel voilà nous
n'avons pas de cours de français pas de
cours de mathématiques tout ça c'est
intégré dans la formation
on va sortir surtout travaillé sur les
compétences métiers notre but c'est
qu'ils soient entièrement autonome
lorsqu'il aura son
son contrat de travail il n'aura pas
l'entreprise n'aura pas besoin de leur
forme et donc on va travailler là dessus
sur l'autonomie et sur le le
professionnel c'est par cet
apprentissage basé sur des activités
concrètes que samira a commencé ce matin
même sa formation d'assistante de vie
aux familles
jusqu'à ce jour je travaille auprès des
passants âgées et handicapées et en fait
c'est une
c'est une formation en vae que je vais
passer
et voilà pour avoir plus pour avoir un
titre professionnel et pour pour avancer
alors je suis perdu c'est vrai qu'il ya
des chaises que j'ai oublié bien sûr ça
a changé un vrai bébé bien sûr je
n'aurais pas lâcher ça c'est sûr mais
comme c'est un petit mâle qu'un donc
voilà j'espère finir ma formation est
allé jusqu'au bout et réussir bien sûr
et après peut-être pourquoi pas
travailler dans dans une crèche ou une
maternelle dans chacune de nos
formations nous avons les périodes
entreprises obligatoire affaire où les
stagiaires vont mettre en application ce
qu'ils ont appris pendant les 5 6
jusqu'à neuf mois de formation dans le
centre pour les stagiaires en alternance
c'est un excellent moyen de se plonger
dans un environnement proche de la
réalité
c'est vraiment très intéressant et ça
nous fait vraiment bien moi par exemple
je suis en radiologie et ses patrons en
plein de choses des fois je suis amené
même au scanner et l'irm en hôpital du
coup c'est super intéressant et on
apprend plus de choses je trouve
on attend sur le terrain que concours
comme je suis en entreprise familiale là
j'aurais pu travailler
directement
sur le terrain mais si je voulais par
exemple changer d'entreprise
il me fallait absolument un diplôme du
coup j'ai trouvé lave pas nous avons
deux types d'apprenants les apprenants
qui suivent la formation complète sur 7
mois environ 950 eur dont cinq semaines
en stage en entreprise cliniques
hôpitaux et parade etc et les contrats
pros ce sont des personnes qui sont qui
font la formation mais une semaine par
mois ici pendant douze 12 semaines donc
une petite année et qui est le reste du
temps pratique ont une pratique
professionnelle dans des entreprises
pour valider une expérience ou pour
trouver un emploi
la formation c'est la clé pour accélérer
et réussir son retour dans le monde du
travail
chaque année 31,6 milliards d'euros sont
investis en france pour permettre à 17
millions de personnes de bénéficier
d'une formation
nous sommes de retour avec vos linda
pour parler des opca donc ces organismes
qui collectent et qui redistribue les
font donc là nous venons de voir des
jeunes qui sont en formation c'est un
des meilleurs moyens pour accéder à un
emploi
les i par exemple ont des salariés et
que l'on souhaite accéder à une
formation pour améliorer ses compétences
au sein de l'entreprise
alors comment ça marche on se rapproche
de son manager et on me demande un
entretien professionnel pour lui faire
part de son souhait de faire une
formation si c'est possible aussi
apporté une chaîne d information c'est à
dire se renseigner un peu sur la
formation qui souhaitent suivre
demandez un devis et ont parlé avec lui
et après la direction décide s'il
souhaite vous la finance et ou pas et
n'a aucune obligation d'accepter à la
première demande donc là je répare sur
un cas concret je suis une entreprise je
souhaite éventuellement prendre
personnes en alternance comment ça
marche pour moi beaucoup d'entreprises
ne le savent pas mais elles peuvent
recruter une personne en alternance sans
avoir cotisé à nokia pour la première
année
elle s'adresse donc elle se réfère alors
que neuf ou leur convention collective
pour définir leur aucun elles prennent
contact avec l'objet en question et elle
leur demande éventuellement le
financement donc si c'est possible de
financer le contrat en question qui les
intéressent en général c'est accepter
est ce qu'on peut parler aussi du conte
sonel de formation tout salarié qui est
en activité au cumul des heures et il a
deux possibilités pour le mettre en
place
donc c'est ça la petite nouveauté avec
la réforme il peut faire une demande cpf
donc bien son employeur sur son temps de
travail
et si son employeur refuse hélas le
droit de demande de faire de partir sur
son hors temps de travail et de partir
en formation sans l'en informer son
employeur
ah oui donc éventuellement s'il y avait
une entente à des accords tout à fait
toujours quand même moyen dans ce il ya
deux possibilités vraiment sur le temps
de travail et hors temps de travail pour
moi je vais faire ma formation et je
peux aller au bout de mon projet alors
donc nous l'avons vu il existe des
moyens d'accéder aux formations
l'entreprise en est un justement nous
allons voir le cas d'une société qui
forme ses salariés
c'est tout de suite avec plus de 120
mille salariés en france l'entreprise
edf déclare miser sur le développement
des compétences et la gestion
prévisionnelle des carrières 85% des
salariés du groupe ont suivi au moins
une formation dans l'année pour les 2300
assistante du groupe
c'est un peu le même parcours
ce sont des personnes qui se sont
souvent rentré sans diplôme dans leur
poste et qui ont progressé au fur et à
mesure de leur vie professionnelle est
donc déjà ce qu'on voit c'est que ces
personnes suivant les postes qu'elles
ont occupé elles ont développé l'une ou
l'autre des compétences mais pas
nécessairement toutes les compétences
dont on aurait besoin aujourd'hui
l'assistante est un peu en fait le
pilier de l'équipe
donc en fait on lui demande des choses
assez nouvelle et est donc nous nous
avons besoin d'adapter la population par
rapport à ces nouvelles compétences
alors quand on a fait le constat qu'on
sait où on veut aller bien du coup on
s'appuie sur des organismes externes
spécialisées par exemple pour nous c'est
l'afp à elancourt
et c'est delphine brunel formatrice à
l'afpa qui travaille avec le groupe edf
depuis 2013 il intervient pour des
modules de perfectionnement sur deux
thématiques la première c'est donc
optimiser son temps et gérer ses
relations la deuxième communiqué
améliorer ses capacités de communication
à l'écrit comme à l'oral pour
l'employeur former ses salariés permet
croissance et innovation mais offre
également la possibilité d'améliorer son
capital humain on développe
globalement la performance de
l'entreprise de toute l'entreprise
parce qu'elles sont un rouage essentiel
de l'entreprise donc ça développe la
valeur ajoutée pour l'entreprise
et puis ça développer leur employabilité
interne donc on les aide à trouver
d'autres postes c'est notamment pour ça
aussi qu'on a développé un
accompagnement à alavés à la validation
des acquis de l'expérience
nous avons investi pour avoir un
accompagnement personnalisé de toutes
les assistantes qui veulent faire ça
devait à eux et ce titre sauf il a reçu
cette année
entré chez edf il ya une petite
vingtaine d'années avec un contrat de
qualification elle a pu obtenir son
diplôme d'assistante de direction par
lavea organisé par son entreprise
j'ai trouvé la démarche est intéressante
parce que je n'avais pas eu l'occasion
jusqu'à présent de de faire valoriser
mai
mes compétences et je souhaitais que
mais compétent soit officiellement
reconnue une valorisation personnelle
mais également la possibilité pour elles
de prendre de nouvelles responsabilités
elle m'a apporté en plus lors des
modules de formation nous avons pu
bénéficier auprès de l'afp à des
compétences supplémentaires sur des
notions que je n'avais absolument pas
comptabilité gestion des choses que je
ne fais pas au quotidien etc
je n'avais jamais eu l'occasion
d'aborder la formation en entreprise un
intérêt commun pour la société comme
pour le salarié nouveauté retour avec
linda ailleurs dont je rappelle que vous
êtes conseillère en formation chez
opcalia donc à notre cas linda par
rapport à la loi elle comme riz du 5
mars 2014 oui des compétences nouvelles
ont été attribués aux opca donc
l'émission ont été étendues qu'est ce
qui a changé exactement on n'est pas si
loin cotisation unique ou 1%
quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise à partir de ça mais vous
versez 1 % sur votre masse salariale la
fin de la 24,83 que l'entreprise devait
remplir avant la fin du compteur dif on
a basculé sur le cpf nous conte personne
de formation hors temps travaillé sur le
ton travail ça c'est la grande nouveauté
est également l'entretien professionnel
dans laquelle devenu obligatoire pour
toutes les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés
alors les opca c'est vraiment un vrai
rôle aussi d'assistance de conseil
auprès des entreprises tout à fait vous
pouvez avoir un besoin de formation sans
connaître sans savoir comment vous y
prendre
vous appelez votre conseiller qui lui va
vous accompagner sur la recherche d'un
organisme de formation et vous aider à
monter votre dossier pour se faire
financer l'information par un look à
linda leur dos merci beaucoup d'avoir
été choisie aujourd'hui est d'avoir
répondu à mes questions je rappelle que
vous êtes conseiller en formation chez
opcalia comptes allemands se retrouvent
pour un prochain mode d'emploi mais
d'ici là connaissent mal vu
[Musique]
à